[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
today's event adjustments I have to
adhere to social distancing ten times as
went by health experts we have second
please if you're not fluent by the time
which is now mandated by state if it's
something and the government how
[Music]
tasty the guys out there Bobby did you
hear thanks for going to be home
McGregor o long-suffering
boy who was had to be the sister-like
voices through AmeriCorps all of years
[Music]
any congratulations president parody mr.
president and I said earlier your
network isn't with me my entire career
the first operation ever adversity 1972
when you go on like a senator you guys
burst me and I able to turn 30 and it's
great to me great to be home
my dad done war and there's a trend I
want to thank one thing fatherhood here
and greater industries show me around
this morning although we I knew of this
establishment the whole time only been
around 100 years and it's this is the
kind of small manufacturing business it
demonstrates that resilience that
creativity a the state of the American
industrial based
oh my child may be new but living
through a time unlike any other in
American history our country is facing
three simultaneous crises pandemic has
infected over 3 million Americans and
caused thus far over 130,000 live Bobby
yeah three times a week I'm on the phone
the National folks the docs were headed
up CDC know their place and before the
expectation is I think you maybe get as
high as 200,000 before it's over and it
shows no signs of slowing down you have
an economic crisis that's almost 18
million Americans out of work
some of the greatest pain inflicted on
small businesses in the communities of
color a national reckoning on the issue
of racial injustice was also its Karma
on top of a widening economic inequity
and a mounting climate crisis he should
be which of these crises is an enormous
talent is testing our strength on
patients are resilient our commitment to
our core values commitment to one
another these duties also depends
tremendous opportunity now for the
future threats we know are just around
the corner an opportunity to address
fundamental inequities of our nation the
growing gap everyone else live up to the
words and the value of trying and our
founding documents this nation now we're
all created equal or entitled to be
treated equally the rest of our life as
is created we treated all the states
could be higher
that's why it's no time divisive
politics were any more about today they
believe that against America will
benefit I know with health crises
economic crisis racial justice crisis
and climate crisis need to come together
as a mirror this is our billable filter
and occurring for our families and for
our communities for every era every man
has a fair return the work they did
legal chance to get ahead
grandpa lived with a boundary read talk
about everybody everybody going deserves
a job this is job everybody more
powerful because everyone could be cut
in a deal as we rebuild the middle class
this time raise everyone along everybody
working families or important literally
took trillion dollars of tax breaks
totally in after three and a half years
they promised health care plan but ever
offered don't bill continue to try to
wipe out and Emmett instead he's taught
me to take health care way from and to
put into people with anatomy course and
over a hundred million people were
covered because they had pre-existing
conditions now
they could have got coverage for before
deliver deliver the world during this
first 18 months I'm going to change that
or in a double occurred when it comes to
copa90 and Ferb let's of doing nothing
other than predicting the fire is here
maybe bank may be okay top to simply
given up wait wait live walk away deep
economic for families are right this
administration may be the big winner
[Music]
[Music]
we'll need up bricks to build it if you
just look around your neighborhood
we're kitchen-table see you build this
country money doesn't determine your
word hey Joey
the world worthy
[Music]
people s to keep here to do a job okay
make your kids will never ever be
substandard movie they had oh no we
built this country are working folks
like your brother you know the last unit
Bill Phillips class that's why a monthly
stage over your labor local diffusible
life taking pride man because the only
way with power corporate America and I
come from a corporate state of the world
Delaware the only way you would use
power with the powers and labor unions
the only one
[Music]
look determination resilience and grit
expect to get up people do it these are
the values take the needle off our small
business job even back the Rubies Bay
some estimates bow before the 100
balance all businesses have been
permanently shut down for food
devastation so enough is enough aspyn
through person parties discuss find out
all business no classrooms a deeper way
through pendant let's up it would be
entrepreneurs get out of debt so they
can start businesses it's time we
thought live under two billions of
dollars with this the growth of this
country
[Music]
[Music]
oh this will be mobilization or since
the great depression of war good experts
have put that in fact
creates their second thing we've seen
the importance of the more resilient
economy long term our press was referred
to this in more detail think is
important that our administration but
behind the threat of attending they gave
all this rendition he shut it all down
he shut down and then it goes we had
inside right now the crazy Chinese
government even as a virus from coming
parks work because it was so afraid if
they walk away from his trade deal it
cost us significant amounts of money
quote
let's not get caught flat-footed again
let's get prepare to meet the challenges
of climate Versalles that means
investing in infrastructure including
creating goods with a mutant jabu
process next week I'll be laying out of
the building modern States and the clean
energy economy how to make sure the
communities who suffer most from
pollution
first benefit from this investment how
to strengthen the union movement how to
make sure the unit of building America
just like they built the middle class
Burton Steven this pandemic and immense
burden of working parents especially men
preparing preparing and they you know
they find some physicians that are
working attempting to work attempt to
take care of the children who were young
at the same time they're aging parents
and we help their suffering and
disabilities I've been especially
parking spaces let's face it it's always
fun let's make it easier to for child
care for everything roasted the mom like
that let's offer more payment work then
often winded all the limit of color were
entrusted to help teach our mountainous
to care for the oldest at the same time
Donald Trump is no idea what it's like
to be a single parent
they're able to get by he doesn't have a
clue there's unconscious he doesn't try
like a lot of you you understand why
that question work to be explicit hope I
know that I've done both is grayed out
really close to us so much we said I
will date out of mobilised hours and
parts will 21st century
cheer giving and education workers
before the managed machine millions of
American working for small counties in
the country telling me to treat these
folks and their families as essential
not just in time for crisis of all time
control these votes the essential work I
think that blinders into taking off from
America those who could afford to stay
at home stay in place it was out there
realized with oceans Booker's back in
the show that nurses they kind of truck
drivers and said mail dispensed work she
he's dad clapping down the street first
responder it's time another clapping
time containing the idea that everyone
if not working eastern middle $15 an
hour
or spent time with my workers and then
so should that correctly organize a
community organizer better pay or
benefits working conditions or insist
that they have State Cemetery conditions
working maybe is possible for him
my kids my work I don't know Justin
Tracy's let's face the job of Obamacare
by ensuring everyone s access must lower
the cost were significant stop surprise
willing to provide public options to
cover the millions of Americans without
health care my hands
let's make everyone sure everyone has
access to good education let's triple
amount of money we spend on title one
schools both title one schools you have
18 of them 18 in title 1 schools
expanded under a means that they're very
low tax bases so there are no trouble
keeping teachers I've triple the amount
of money we spend on those 15 billion a
year the 45 we raising this knowledge of
the teachers in those schools of those
sixty thousand dollars a year making
sure every single solitary child it's
three four and five able to go to school
take care all the data shows and studies
showed whether it is in the youth
Lawrence University and anywhere around
that that increases over fifty eight
percent to change that that child will
all the way through graduate without
having trouble now I didn't put a big
difference there I think because of this
pandemic everyone as we can do an
appreciation of just how hard our
teachers were put into the job let's
give them the resources and support they
need to get through this crisis in the
power of next generation American ground
what's pavement he's not somebody else
they're the children those children are
the country who are nationally business
laws our teachers teachers console
Senate races needs our conference and
attendant racial equality in our country
isn't just about police reform it's
about human deep normal disintegration
of the races in this nation so we need
we need to dedicate agenda expand
affordable housing Investment found in
black today API Native American
entrepreneurs make real the promise to
the whole provided there should be youth
mount even itis balance on cynically
claimed that he's defending American
terrorism by embracing the Confederate
flag in public monuments over generals
who were developing its and treason
against the United States of America
people are trying to determine a grip
this nation apart you think Donald Trump
is an annotated 360,000 Pennsylvania's
bought on the side of Community News
live Confederate by including more black
soldiers coming from the state
defenseman and any other state condition
I think he has any clue that 33,000 and
civilians died Mistura war fighting
against everything that blacks this
world I see different America one that
despite all our flaws and shortcomings
and families still after more than two
extensions dedicated to equality liberty
and human dignity
challenge we face today or move the
biggest Niners we have to come together
in this country to solve
there's no other way I got criticized
through the primary my state run for
three reasons
your store the soul of America
I know for our country not make it
[Music]
yourself
period
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]